[Musique]
ces marathons permet effectivement des
réunions des athlètes la jeunesse et
pouvoir parler du niger beaucoup d'une
région bête de pouvoir échanger sur la
paix sur le vivre ensemble renforcer la
cohésion entre les communautés entre les
différentes couches les huit régions du
pays et des pays de la sous région
[Musique]
c'est une région très fragile et c'est
important de venir ici d'apporter notre
soutien
nous occidentaux de ne pas oublier le
niger ne pas oublier ces pays là et
d'être là dans la fraternité la
solidarité
[Musique]
là c'est vraiment des émotions très
fortes on a coréen moitié de marathon en
plein de désir et la deuxième partie on
a l'accord dans la centre de ville
d'agadès que le spectacle de l'audience
[Musique]